it is quite a read when you go to
cbssports.com and see the number of
coaches that were interviewed
anonymously casting votes and who is the
most overrated and underrated head
coaches in college football and the man
who put this all together for CBS sports
college football analyst chip Patterson
here on the show how you doing chip I'm
doing all right
how are you doing I'm doing fine so
let's let's get into this how many
coaches did you speak to for this piece
I personally did not speak to all of
them this is a four or five person
effort and our total was somewhere
between 2030 and I think that our final
claim was that it was one-fifth I don't
know who all who said what we divvied up
the questions I think we asked about ten
questions this year we wrote stories on
five or six of them one of them being
too overrated and underrated and I do
think that it's important rich to let
people know that you know college
football coaches notoriously paranoid a
lot of them told me no a lot of them you
know had no interest in participating
with this so put yourself in the mindset
of a coach who has agreed to talk some
smash about rival coaches and I think
that's like like as we start to really
parse through these responses you need
to remember that this coach has
definitely come into this knowing
exactly what they're doing getting ready
to anonymous anonymous lis trash arrival
to a national outlet right and so the
most overrated coaches in college
football according to your poll willie
Taggart and james franklin at 20% why do
you think you know it's funny what did
you glean there chip I I think that if
you asked media members myself included
to list some of the rising stars in the
profession
it would probably match an overrated
poll of current college football coaches
because every college football coach is
going to think that any adoration from
the media from someone outside of the
close-knit coaching community that if
they're getting this adoration and all
the sudden I'm not well then yeah I
thought that the the overrated portion
of this brought out what I would allege
to even be borderline jealous
and I thought that the underrated
portion of this we saw a lot of coaches
pay homage to a coach who has maybe
helped them out along the way yeah the
most underrated coach in college
football David Shaw and Chris Peterson
to 12 percent who are the coaches that
made both lists chip we had David Shaw
made both lists
and I think that one of the quotes that
we use from that is that you know the a
lot of the you know ways to be
complimentary of Shaw have to do with
the way he has positioned the Stanford
program obviously Jim Harbaugh doing so
much to get it into a great place at the
top of college football winning that
Orange Bowl David Shaw what he's been
able to do is modernize it and a lot of
that's been on the recruiting trail and
so I think that being able to take a
school like Stanford within football
history and put it into a position where
I mean was it four of the last six
pac-12 North titles have gone to the
Cardinal right I mean that that is crazy
to think about and so the you know where
you were and where you are now has media
members and members of the football
community like myself and putting a lot
of praise on David Shaw and I remember
one of the quotes for David Shaw being
overrated was more just that he gets a
little bit too much fluff and headlines
is what this one coach taught Patterson
to CBS Sports joining me here Tom Herman
and Kirk Ferentz wound up on both lists
as well I mean Tom Herman I I guess he's
overrated why because he got the Texas
job and he's underrated why because he
he he got the Texas job you know that's
what standing right there what what you
would read from Willie Taggart you know
just a little bit of bordering on
jealousy of like wow and he he that was
a very quick move and I think that what
the coaches don't understand is that the
hires are being made by athletic
directors and university presidents that
are probably thinking as much if not
more on you know what a certain coach
would be able to lead them to I have no
beef to pick with Tom Herman I will say
that I will never forget him mocking
Missouri quarterback drew Locke in the
bowl game and my
the celebration of them.i I took note of
that for Tom Harmon but in general I
think Tom Herman did such a great job at
Houston at creating very quickly
creating a culture that motivated not
only the football program but the whole
Houston community and anytime when
you're asking a college football coach
to be a leader of young men there
anytime you're able to see that
motivational skill and that is something
that I'm going to award as him being a
solid head coach I think Tom Herman
while he might appear on both lists from
these peers I think that right now he is
rightly rated with a bright future chip
Patterson here on the show so there's
five other coaches that were lumped
together as the most overrated coach in
college football and we could see lower
around that two coaches that received a
vote as to being overrated Jimbo Fisher
being one and then Nick Saban being the
other were you the one who interviewed
the one who said Nick Saban was
overrated or was that a colleague of
yours it was a colleague of mine and I I
didn't even get a chance to see come on
yeah who collect what coach it was Chip
I wasn't I I will tell you the coach
that some of the interview responses I
got were definitely targeted attacks at
arrival but they were not the the
comment about Nick Saban so you know I
didn't hear it
but I read the cheat I do a lot of a
cheater called him a cheetah done sit
done fit real well with me the only way
that I could sort of you know put myself
in the in the headspace of the coach who
might have said that is that they they
took this a little lightly and certainly
didn't realize the way that it was going
to be taken in publication who are the
other things that was a coach that was a
coach who used the anonymity anonymity
of the activity and ran a little bit far
lies I think so but who are the other
coaches that were that that that were
reviewed is overrated that didn't get
listed here do you have that information
let's say you're looking at your notes
right there because it says I'm coaching
you know like Willie Tiger James
Franklin Kirk Ferentz Lane Kiffin come
now he's at Florida Atlantic right now
he's at Boca yeah he's in Boca guys but
the quote about Lane Kiffin is what was
it he's if you're if you're born on
third base that's great but don't act
like you hit a triple he's he's Lane
Kiffin man I mean I think he's really
right we're right where people rate him
so you don't know the other coaches were
specific I'm sorry rich I don't have the
full database I wasn't even allowed
access to all these answers the secrecy
through all this really put me in a
tough position on it I'm happy to be
speaking to you now all right so last
one for you do you have any information
on what's going on with Ohio State and
no what what what to expect an
announcement coming in this week for
sure
to put everything to bed as best they
can in Columbus I I don't know how have
you where have you settled on this
because I'm in a position where I
I know number one throughout all of
these twists and turns don't ever doubt
Brett McMurphy's reporting it's just
like a stone cold that is that is
something that I hold true and I believe
that he has done a lot of work and a lot
of hard work that the other journalists
and writers haven't done so you know in
terms of the sideshow of all this I have
mostly leaned with Brett former
colleague somebody who I would call a
friend who's helped me out a lot
throughout my young time in this
industry but at this point I'm in a
place of feeling like I'm making a
prediction and the the way that this is
going to break who knows but my
prediction is that we'll have some
admission of fault for Urban Meyer's
comments at Big Ten media days and rich
I'm not expecting much admission of
fault beyond that from the head football
coach and there might be a punishment
that comes with lying to the media of
Big Ten media days but I don't think
that's a fireable offense and so I keep
coming back to this place where I do
think that there will be some amount of
punishment and admission of fault but it
will not extend to Urban Meyer admitting
that there were any missteps on his part
for his handling of allegations of
domestic violence against Zach Smith has
Ohio State obtained enough information
in its investigation to suggest
otherwise
I think that that might be difficult and
so I it makes me feel a little
uncomfortable but I'm I'm still feeling
like we might see Urban Meyer you know
was their fifth game of the season is in
against Penn State yeah I think we might
see him on the sideline for that I think
we'll see him on the sideline the week
before against Tulane I think if they
find any wrongdoing that is not fireable
for an offense or an offense that will
have some sort of a lawsuit that
there'll be some sort of a suspension
and he'll be back on the sidelines then
chip I appreciate the time thanks for
calling it absolutely well you got a
chip Patterson here on CBS Sports the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience